homeopathy may be the most controversial
but also the most popular alternative
medicine
while some argue against it others swear
by its great power and effectiveness
how does homeopathy work how did it
become what it is today
and what can modern medicine learn from
[Music]
it
the first principle of homeopathy is
like cures like
remedies use ingredients that cause the
symptoms you want to cure
in practice that means that remedies
against fever
could for example be made from
belladonna which also causes fever
a mixture based from b venom is used to
treat itchy swellings
and so on the second principle is a
special method of preparation called
potentization
the idea is that diluting and agitating
the ingredients activates their curative
powers and enhances their effect
to do this the ingredient is dissolved
in alcohol or distilled water
homeopaths take one part of the solution
and mix it with nine parts of water
diluting it down to one tenth of its
original concentration and shaking it
what you have now is a one x potency one
part ingredient and nine part solvent
named after the roman numeral x for ten
now this process is repeated take one
part mix it with nine parts of pure
water
and shake it vigorously now you have two
eggs
you do this again and again until you
reach the desired grade of potency
the finished remedy is then taken orally
or sometimes it's applied as little
sugar pellets
that are sold as globally a 20x potency
for example is like dissolving one
aspirin pill in the water volume of the
whole atlantic
[Music]
but many are much more extreme like 30c
for example
c means that the mixture has one part
ingredient and 99 parts water
so the commonly sold 30c mixture means
one part ingredient
and one million billion billion billion
billion billion billion
parts of water if we wanted a globally
pill with a single atom of the original
ingredient
then our pill would be the diameter of
the distance between the earth and the
sun
150 million kilometers a pill so massive
that it would collapse into a black hole
under its own mass
because of this potentization is one of
the biggest criticisms of homeopathy
the extreme dilution is supposed to make
the ingredients more potent
but on a physical level this doesn't
really make sense
most homeopathic remedies are diluted so
much that not a single atom of the
active ingredient is left in them
the explanation of why the mixtures
still work is that
shaking the mixture after every dilution
leaves behind
a spirit-like essence of the ingredient
basically
the idea is that water remembers what
was put into it
but if this were true then every
substance that ever met a drop of water
would leave an essence behind and lead
to unpredictable effects when it was
accidentally ingested
[Music]
think of all the stuff that lives and
floats in the oceans every sip of water
would be a supercharged homeopathic
cocktail
so how did homeopathy become the most
successful alternative medicine
in the 18th century medicine was very
different from today
treatments like bloodletting left the
patient worse off than before
so german physician zamo alhanuman
wanted a non-invasive
natural way of healing and developed
homeopathy
and in fact homeopathic hospitals were
soon successful
because doing no harm beats doing harm
hanuman imposed very strict rules on his
patients first you had to avoid coffee
tea alcohol spicy food sweet food
no old cheese no onions no meat no
clothes made from sheep's wolf but also
no sedentary work
no sitting inside in stuffy air no warm
rooms no riding horses
no napping no playing games no
masturbation
and of course no reading pornographic
texts and many more
then and only then would his remedies
work according to the inventor of
homeopathy
of course all of these instructions are
ignored and not talked about today
medicine has changed a lot in the last
150 years
never before in human history have we
enjoyed a comparable level of health
never have we lived as long and this is
largely due to the new tools we've
developed
modern diagnostics double-blinded
studies and scientific evaluation
to check and prove which stuff works
thanks to these tools
after countless studies and reviews we
know beyond a shadow of a doubt
that homeopathy does not have any effect
beyond placebo
but even so who cares why it works if it
helps people
maybe you tried it and felt better or
you know someone that got over a
horrible disease
while using homeopathic remedies and
there are plenty of reports of it
working for children and animals
what do we make of these experiences the
placebo effect is very real
and not imaginary no matter how smart
you are
you're not immune to it if people
believe that something will help them
feel better
their trust alone has the desired effect
and it's been proven that the placebo
effect can be transferred
children and animals rely on their
parents or keepers and
are in tune to their emotions if a
parent has a lot of trust in a treatment
and eases up
this can help a child relax and help
relieve symptoms
this can also be observed with animals
who react strongly to the body language
cues of the people caring for them
but the most powerful tool of homeopathy
is time our bodies are survival machines
infections pass on their own after a few
days but if you take some remedy when
you already feel sick
and then start getting better it feels
like it did indeed kill you
well actually it would have happened
anyway the homeopathy industry likes to
play the gentle alternative to big
pharma
but the homeopathic industry is big
billions of dollars are made with
extreme profit margins
the homeopathy industry has its own
lobby organizations
and fights its enemies as hard as it can
a lot of money is on the line
globally the market is expected to reach
over 17 billion by 2024
some critics even argue that the
homeopathic industry is bad for public
health
because it creates distrust in proven
medicine
the belief in homeopathy correlates with
skepticism about vaccinations
this can discourage people to seek the
help they need when their lives or the
lives of their children are on the line
but there is actually a key to the
success of homeopathy
that we could and should copy the first
consultation with a homeopath
can take hours and is very personal for
a patient who's already been on a
pilgrimage from doctor to doctor
this level of attention and empathy can
make a huge difference to their
well-being
even if the conversation was not the
point of the therapy modern medicine is
efficient
it saves millions of lives each year but
it's also a strictly organized system
tight budgets force doctors and nurses
to deal with lots of patients
consultations need to be time efficient
diagnoses made quickly
treatments fast which can leave patients
feeling invisible
scared and left behind this is what
modern medicine can learn from
homeopathy
it meets a human need that has been left
unfulfilled
we need to make time for the individual
again see people
not numbers but as important as empathy
is
it's not a substitute for actual
treatment
faith can move mountains but sugar water
can't cure cancer
after a short break of a few years
quartzquez is back in german
thanks to the support of funk we have
relaunched the german channel and
are beginning to upload a video every
one to two weeks
besides redoing our favorite videos
there'll be a number of videos that will
not exist in english for a while
check out the channel here tell us what
you think and subscribe and watch a few
if the channel goes well the german
videos might become a regular thing for
years
and we might even do more languages
[Music]
you